in Brighton giving us an update on the
search for the missing child
Constance Martin and Mark Gordon
arrested they've been looking for their
newborn let's listen
and we've traveled across the country as
part of our searches for this baby
we are truly devastated by the outcome
and we know this emotion is being felt
here in Brighton and across the country
today
we know there are still many unanswered
questions and it is important that we
give the investigation team the time and
space they need to establish more
details about the circumstances of this
tragic death
at this stage we've not yet been able to
confirm the baby's gender and a
post-mortem examination has not yet
taken place
despite this based on our inquiries
we've carried out so far
We Believe sadly the baby may have been
dead for some time before they were
found
it's too early for us to provide a more
specific date
because we believe the death occurred
during the course of a missing person
investigation
we have made a mandatory referral to the
independent office of police conduct
this is a standard protocol for such
circumstances
I can also confirm that Constance Martin
and Mark Gordon remain in custody at
this time and the warrant for further
detention that was granted yesterday
will take us through to late evening
officers from the Met will remain in
this area for the coming days
and I'll now hand over to my colleague
Chief superintendent James Collis from
Sussex police
good afternoon
we have seen an outpouring of public
sorrow following yesterday's
heartbreaking discovery and have been
overwhelmed by kind messages and support
to those involved in this challenging
search and investigation
the latest developments mean that the
investigation is moving into a new phase
and while the Metropolitan Police will
remain in the area the large police
presence for the search will be scaled
back
our neighborhood officers will continue
to be in the local community to offer
support and address any concerns
I would once again like to thank the
public for their patience and support
through this operation and express my
gratitude to the huge number of people
who have helped or offered to help in
any way that they can
it is truly appreciated
we will continue to support the
Metropolitan police's inquiries and ask
that the investigation is given space to
proceed as we establish the full facts
of what has happened thank you very much
everyone thank you very much
Gordon